[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
did you take the SATs I took the SATs
you have what you got 1100 really yeah
pretty good
man yeah it got me into Riders yeah you
said you played defensive end and
fullback yeah were you playing both ways
in every game yeah both sides of the
ball Tom yeah well we were small school
yeah we're not that big he's playing
every page
throwing it to himself Papa drops back
throws the papa papa with a great catch
oh tackled by Papa
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
all right here comes officer
we're having a nice big round of
applause for mayor Papa everybody
be right back with more news from Papa
I was on uh you know Colbert a few
months ago yeah and I told the story
which is true that uh that Ellis was
still asking like to have his ass wiped
right like a couple months ago he was
like I pooped you gotta wait I'm like
come on dude you got to wipe your ass
he's like I'll do it when I'm older and
I'm like how old he's like 16. I was
like there's no [ __ ] way I'm wiping
your ass so you're 16. and Dad yeah I'm
like [ __ ] hey there's I'm not getting
you a car
um
so he saw that he saw that video and
like he was like you know trying to
figure out the hell's going on he was
like what are you doing where are you
talking about me yeah and then I got
home last night and I was like hey do
you know what I do he was like yeah you
tell jokes you're a comedian I was like
that's right he goes you're like Ellis
won't wipe his ass but like do wipe my
ass
yeah
Mom tell this guy I'll wipe my ass down
she was like it's true he doesn't need
you yeah fellas it's been a while you've
been gone for a long time
I guarantee you one thing to be true I
get if I say one true thing this week
it's this
and everything that I've said to you
Jasmine oh that's sweet yeah that's true
you look nervous no you know you know
I've been telling you could prove it
yeah yeah that's all good stuff yeah
yeah
so one thing this is
this is as true as true can be this is
as true as true TV
which is where my best friend Sal's show
is on and I love that Network yeah and
that show so so
this is literally
anybody's gonna enjoy watching this
episode I
think Chris is melting down
what do you feel dude what do you feel
right now so what dude I feel I feel
honestly it's one of the here's how I
feel even though I'm sitting
cross-legged I feel like I got two feet
on the ground yeah I feel stable and
sturdy and rounded yeah and grounded and
and um and I also feel like um you know
I was planning to go home to my family
to not miss an event in my daughter's
life but I'm too high to drive so I
guess I gotta watch the World Cup with
Mike
you gotta stay in the city for safety
that's what it is
I know it was a recital for your father
but
the annual father's recital
not even Father's Day just father's
recital
oh my God oh my God
let's see what she has let me see if you
agree with what she says controversial
opinion but if you have a token white
and you're hanging out with your friend
group of color
you need to ask permission from
everybody in the group to bring your
white friend like don't just bring them
ask for explicit permission from
everyone because just because you're
comfortable with them doesn't mean that
everybody's comfortable with them I
might not be in the mood to deal with
white shenanigans that day that's that's
all it says any other thing
like don't don't let them think they're
a good white person so what do you think
if you I don't like why Shenanigans
never like that who does everyone since
I've been in this country yeah you're
sick of White Chicks [ __ ] around
frolicking around so if you're with a
group of Asians
do you have to ask permission to bring a
white
well I do mention it
how do you still get the permission how
do you say it yeah I'm coming all right
all right I'm calling do I get a
difference I'm going to call okay the
main guy yeah Ling
all right no well the link doesn't know
oh so yeah that's why maybe I won't
bring you oh my God
and it just feels weird right so you
know I mean I think that's on you
was that white Shenanigans
I walk into a big room of all ages
yeah what are we eating guys so
um they're all like he brought supplies
dogs get treated differently down south
though yeah dude like so many of the
rescues come from the south like I think
80 of the dogs don't don't actually
don't look this up no look this up I
think 87 of the dogs walk around are
tied to like an old clothesline 365 days
a year and get beat by the entire family
and nobody feeds them but I think 85 of
the dogs blow the Mason-Dixon Line are
tied outside
you could be the new Abraham Lincoln
yeah I should be you could emancipate
barclamation
how do they keep doing it the
Emancipation Proclamation
yes
straight back to business back to
business it's time yeah brother I'll
tell you what man I'll tell you what I
mean it doesn't get better than the
emancipation
[Laughter]
this whole thing was the oyster and we
just got to the Pearl we found it it is
what it is a lot of people are going to
sit back and say they've lost it they
don't have the juice anymore
Emancipation Proclamation and go they're
reaching higher levels holy [ __ ] this
thing's about to be a household [ __ ]
podcast this is gonna replace the
Nightly News for sure women are going to
turn off the murder mysteries and go
hold on a second wait a second hold on
these guys just bashing women for two
hours into in between talking Nazis
what do you mean that you're Ben's booty
holes what are you saying
I sometimes like men's booty holes if
that's the only thing available now in
prison yeah there's um
there's a reputation of people maybe
doing that where
one of the parties is unconsensual yeah
are you into that haha let's go really I
mean if it's me doing it I don't like it
right well no not me doing it of course
of course and it's scary as hell dog now
can't you empathize if you don't want
somebody doing that to you that you
maybe shouldn't be doing it to them nah
what put you in prison
oh all right
um I'm gonna call the police
okay well I better be balancing out of
here then if that's your reaction to
this but I appreciate that sandwich your
finances gave me down my throat
could I trust that you're gonna go right
straight back to jail
no then I'm gonna call the police
fine I'll go back to jail then
are you gonna go back to jail
yeah
okay
[Music]
leave my wallet
there's a guy who just had sex with me
and I think he had your wallet
abs look good people break here is
blurred
the guy out
oh
get it right
it just had sex with me and I had to get
your wallet
so
[Laughter]
did you not just hear what I said well
did he go straight to jail
he did
okay all right because he said he would
how much money would you spend per month
waxing your back oh
the I don't shave anything you know I
don't know never anywhere I've never
shaved I don't shave my chest I don't
shave my back you don't landscape a
little no oh [ __ ] though really yeah
really a little hair on your back at all
dude maybe a tiny bit I mean
I'm checking it out it's pretty clean
there's one little mole with a little
Stringer yo with all the steroids you
think you'd be way hairier I'm not sure
I believe this yeah that's fine that's a
lot of testosterone to be you know what
I mean you know I mean a lot of people
have been asking too like uh what are
the side effects you know I've taken I'm
like I'm probably the wrong person to
ask you know but because I saw two side
effects that are pretty serious and
that's again why you got to get
monitored right I saw my lipids I saw my
my liver I also saw my estrogen you know
get a little [ __ ] up oh um what was
happening well but that's the thing I
saw it on on a lip on a blood panel I
didn't feel anything you know from it
like
um you didn't notice like your story's
getting a little bit more boring
they started watching shitty movies
you didn't notice that at all like the
costumes
for no reason refusing to apologize
freezing at a restaurant
you know I was looking for a girlfriend
right now I didn't show you this yet but
yo what's up I'm looking for a female
rapper
that lives here in Pueblo what was the
name of that that wants to record some
music with me
so yeah and get at me
because I'm home all day
and everything
and plus
so we could do some video shoots oh
video shoots
more music as well
that's all I gotta say so peace out okay
that's all you gotta say that's all I
gotta say first of all he didn't have to
say he was home all day I think she was
implied by
yeah very cool but I want I have so many
questions this is a dude that you've
seen a video from before the first time
first time first time call I'm pretty
curious now long time first time yeah
because is this I'm not sure if mock
turtleneck is his best move oh yeah I
don't know he looks like he's been
hitting them shrugs
that's his rap name shruggy g I know man
that's a weird but I don't know if I go
if you don't have it yeah you mocked
turtleneck is not yours I'm looking for
a female rapper I'm home all day all day
also we can shoot videos and he's like
two three four for music
I I wonder I'm so curious if he got any
takers no oh no no you don't think
there's somebody for you don't think
somebody out there was like maybe I'm
trying to rap too someone's got to be
somebody who's desperate for sure right
now here's the thing though it's it just
shows you how important marketing is if
he was like even in a music store yeah
like there's just keyboards behind it so
true and he shot the same video he was
like yo I'm looking for a female rapper
in this so true that alone so we'll be
like this dude is he a producer he's
just out with trees and [ __ ] yeah he's
just really true he does it all day you
know it looks like his mom said don't
make those videos in the house
and I'm sure if a female rapper or
anyone came over they'd be like so
where's your setup and he was like well
let's just let's just spit game right
now
he would it would there would be nothing
to record with and there's no sidewalk
that always bothers me yeah
I also he did this all wrong which is
why he's on the show yeah
I would also say that like you know you
have to if you're gonna be a rapper and
rap is all about you know your words and
how smoothly you get things out of your
mouth this was a very choppy yeah very
choppy I think though he's looking for a
female rapper maybe he's like I am a
producer I know maybe he's like that's
my strength producers are weird I know a
few of them they're weird as [ __ ] I
think he needs a chain I'm not gonna lie
to you I think that that'd be a long-ass
rope together
[Laughter]
take it off his bicycle yeah
did you guys get party buses in high
school no you know we did a couple it
was just a BJ Fest it was great on the
bus on the bus girls didn't know what to
do as they were like I didn't know what
to do
well you're just the tall seats so you
can't really should I do you can't
really dance should we have a
conversation oh yeah we should just suck
everyone off right you're a lot of
things to talk about so we gotta get
this party bus yeah it's just us four in
the town sucking each other's dicks
[Music]
it's just coming on each other's faces
everyone's like this is the worst
episode of
what are we supposed to do talk yeah on
a podcast we blew each other
stab cannonballed yeah that would be
that would be a nice that would be
another way to torture someone who's
just poo cocky their face
until they drown in a marauding tribes
come uh yeah it's like Chinese water
torture yeah but it's Japanese
yeah they just all come on your face
until you drown it you can't breathe
it's covering your knot sexy you would
be good for the government have you
thought about working for the feds no
but it is good you let it dry there so
it kind of it closes the eyes it closes
the mouth yeah their hands can't take it
off
horrible it would be that's one of the
word that that might be one of the worst
ways to die I also don't uh Ling Chi is
also I think about that you learn that
from Bobby yeah
and match with this girl on hinge right
yeah and I go so you know we match and I
go hey oh hey how do you spell that what
that's my opening oh no that's not a
good one I know I've never done that but
I've never done that I'll tell you what
we like after that go ahead how do what
do you like I like high with a lot of
eyes I've done that then they never
respond hi yeah no okay hey yo she
responded but she responded how do you
spell heyo first so I went
h-e-y-o exclamation mark hey uh I didn't
answer back she did oh but this is a
response okay good
on one of my profile pics is a photo of
me and Theo Von oh no and she goes hey I
don't want you to feel like [ __ ] but can
you tell Theo Von I think you're [ __ ]
he's hot oh that's rough and I literally
almost started to cry oh God
exactly that was the first thought in my
mind like why would you know that piece
of [ __ ] right I think you put a picture
yeah why would you be there because I
thought it was like going to be a thirst
trap you know what no one is kind of you
don't no one will care about a picture
of you and me no let's do that yeah
let's take it right now here's what
we're gonna do after this podcast I am
going to put take a photo of you and I
yeah right yeah sitting on the couch
right and I'm gonna use that as one of
my profiles yeah please yeah yeah but if
I get any of like hey can you tell John
Stamos I said hi yeah it'll break my
[ __ ] heart you don't want to do that
maybe we should you're going about it
wrong that's why I'm asking you this is
a trick girls have known for a long time
am I right you want to take a picture
with someone who's much less attractive
yep yep you don't want to be famous
famous is fine but either way you want
to go you're famous enough you're famous
so you want to go with someone less
attractive like take a picture Tim Dylan
with Tim Dillon right right then you
look like John Stamos
I want to be the John Stamos in the
phone all right you don't want to have
John Stamos in the photo but
theoretically I mean what you're saying
is that you're you're already out
allowed saying that Theo Von is more
attractive than I am you have a
beautiful energy
let's talk about it Matt this is your
first time doing stand-up comedy ever uh
yes sir first time you've been touching
him Mike congratulations very good right
you're ridiculously bad with the
microphone but here's what you ought to
do
on your way to do a set next time stop
at the convenience store and just tell
them the joke and if nobody laughs at it
man I gotta be honest like it's I'm glad
I bombed my first time because I've told
the story people have left but it's like
it's trying to I trying to put into one
minute you know what do you say what
don't you say dick has already been seen
now it's how you want to talk about it
well the hard part is to get up here and
you did that and then you're learning
some mic skills so you write a joke
you're on your way buddy yeah I wanted
to kill Tony for my first time and I
know there's a couple of uh like a
couple of open mics you can do so I'm
gonna start doing those now too but it's
good yeah you should have you should
have maybe done those first oh
if I'm gonna bomb like I would love to
get roasted by the best so I mean like
might as well do like you know I guess
so but you don't really deserve it yet
oh yeah you kind of have to earn to get
roasted by the best you just sort of
want them yeah that was just great
Lottery and you're like that it was just
regular suck dude that was regular suck
I'm not gonna not argue at all you
deserve to get roasted by the worst is
what you mean right now at this point in
your career I'll get roasted by anybody
you need a homeless guy to tell you that
[ __ ] ain't funny Holmes I have an
interesting app uh story that happened
to me that I thought you might find
pretty weird and cool it's kind of like
a Ghost Story meets Highway to Heaven
type of thing okay you know yeah it's uh
also old enough to Remember
by the way I think Chilly Willy did an
episode of Highway to Heaven too
remember he was possessed yeah
Michael Landon pouring holy water on a
little Chilly Willy penguin yeah yeah oh
catboy yeah this little stitched where's
Waldo cap
by the way am I the only guy that
doesn't give a [ __ ] where Waldo is
[ __ ] off I hope Waldo's stuck in a bear
trap in Montana getting eaten by
mountain lions that [ __ ] googly eyes
he's giving everybody eyes she's
squinting and looking for this
[ __ ] in a [ __ ] Waldo it's kind
of like it should be like where's pervo
like he's like he's always there kind of
behind the Eiffel Tower behind the
bushes it's like dude stay out of my
yard I feel like he's watching me
undress at night
anyway sorry I digressed do you like the
most [ __ ] up dream about Johnny I
texted Joe as soon as I woke up I just
remember walking in New York City you
know how there's like the metal like um
the the stairs to go down in front of
like a lot of like stores like it'll be
like basically yeah we know how that is
why why are you talking to us like we're
stupid people don't I'm from New York
City wouldn't be able to imagine what
that is yeah Bob there's an audience
yeah dude yeah but if you're saying it's
stupid he's going
the gas digital page stop [ __ ]
pausing just spit it out so I had a
dream that Joe it was open he wasn't
looking we were just talking and then he
fell through the the grace why are you
pause it why are you doing that but then
he [ __ ] hit his [ __ ] he didn't
even have a chin but he hit his chin on
the other side of the thing so his head
snap back and he just [ __ ] Tom Segura
at the bottom of the [ __ ] uh thing
died yeah dude no I don't know if you
were dead but then I I remember being
like oh right you had to get to a spot
yeah cholesterol
you didn't hear about it
that's crazy not die buddy looking up
right now look it up it happened I dude
last night I swear on Bobby Kelly's
son's life that Tom Segura is dead I
also swear on Bobby's son's life and
it's not gonna be funny if he actually
is dead how about the reaction to Tom's
a girl being dead buddy he's gone so
you're giving it away buddy he had a
[ __ ] shirt though he wouldn't have
made that joke right then yes he would
he would I hate Tom Segura good riddance
I love Tom he's one of my favorite
people I've met he's overselling or
whatever dude she's on his phone show me
we actually have it don't treadmill we
actually [ __ ] Joe we have a a
computer with a lady behind it yeah
bring it up producers are really [ __ ]
crackers what am I gonna do hit her
she's a woman I used to be able to yell
at mush I can't yell at him we'll see
the [ __ ] headline I mean it takes
[ __ ] do we have internet she's not
dead Dr Steve dude buddy are you friends
with him I didn't know you were friends
with him I'm friendly yeah I mean I'm
friendly with him too and I'm sad about
it but I'm not now Bobby went to
Friendly's with photography
how's it going
[Music]